Oh welcome everyone happy monday to
megabit you will notice that I am NOT
peterbrown atomic Shay's not Peter Brown
either Peter Brown what is he doing he's
in Fort Worth he's in Fort Worth tending
to extremely embarrassing foot fungus oh
yeah maybe today I'm megabit we just
received a priority message from general
pepper because whole account will
playing starfox 64 the best starfox game
I know right oh this is definitely one
of my top 10 favorite games of all time
without uh not one of my top two how
wish but I played the heck out of it is
you hate fun see the enemies are at the
gates Rome is falling before our eyes
his the entire universe is coming apart
under and rosters amazing and only now
this general pepper decided to lift the
counter and make the phone call that's
all I'm saying plus he's got all these
pictures of himself up over all the
buildings what's up at that it's a
little big brother I know right Little
Big Brother a little bit of an ego
problem a little bit that's just I've
just got some beef in general I mean
Falco could also be there for the money
well he's a mercenary hasn't much and he
knows his share will be better because
slippies definitely that's right slippy
is not gonna be a woman a togepi who got
lucky one yeah oh man Pepe's on his last
leg and foxes socks is the only
competition well he's banking on his
father's made
and his father didn't even do that well
that's true his dad totally got captured
he squealed real good before he died
character so dark by the way so
basically born in the mud I admit you
know there was some other important
point what was I gonna make about Star
Fox laws
so a few weeks ago Emily Rogers is one
of the or now she just might be view
finest I had doesn't support monitor
journalist ok it's kind of her specialty
she wrote about nitey how she doesn't
think there will be another and the
reason why is that this is a hard core
friend these are super shooters are by
definition shortly engine it really
playable skill-based big your course or
channeling i feei and their gear towards
hardcore I'm not here to be a little
thick of it flaky m0 is the one that we
kind of scary yeah that's all f0 is is
even more hard before it really is and
the doesn't doesn't love the hardcore
always liked it that because I want to
gain like Donkey Hong Kong sure Duncan
country tropical freeze is export and
anyone here play it and it's hard like
it's the best of every world huffing it
kinda like those kind of game later life
you like games you like this you're
close to have zero works like if you
like games and you're super intense
you're a real extreme dude yeah I don't
know it was I mean Donkey Kong has the
added bonus of everybody knows your
donkey kong he is oh yeah it makes you
scared good please tell you should just
shocked us by have it in them like
we we suck we suck all of our extra
money into this starbucks we're banking
on this they should show that up Indrani
the enemy my anyone you want to get to
the interview higher art form whoa all
right vol they're both great at what
they do so he says we can borrow ideas
for movies usually here Miyamoto
synthesis Nintendo usually is its own
thing there yeah show games they love ya
they exist so he says we borrow dramatic
camera movements okay in the use of
real-time voice voices real time so in
star fox we've no longer ventrolateral
boys i know we found that the movie gave
us a fuller movie like experience yeah
the overall experience was normally okay
cool but yeah he does save movies our
passive experience and games are active
that is like the best and worst things
about games by the way aim so quickly
you know the theory about like the first
I don't like 30 seconds of a YouTube
video is worthless if you're right yeah
yeah i have i've heard that youtube
fools so the beginning of so many games
are now kind of worthless where's like
Star Fox you're kinda you start and when
you start the ground running like I'm
not you just hit the bug like if you
don't want to watch you can skip the
opening you just get both opening
cinematics and within a minute you just
turn it on hit start hit start and
you're either going yeah the game you're
pulling that [ __ ] cuz yesterday I was
calling a little mercenary kings and
there was like this metal gear what is
the conversation called a melon area
where there's
like you said the decimal number Oh what
is that thing the UH now I can only the
codec thank you look there's a Kodak so
calm I was like that's not what it's
called there's a code a conversation
that was like not anything not what I
really just want to shrink some dude but
you need context for what you're doing I
really don't I really don't need
contacts what so now we sound grumpy I
know now I hate but we also love great
well the thing is we play games cuz we
love them yeah right if someone who
doesn't love this I'd be like someone
who's not a me in steps are farts in
Super Nintendo a lot of people love that
game or the message i'm asking yes okay
in my opinion I prefer 64 why is it the
best mean I feel I mean starfox on Super
Nintendo gets bonus points for like
doing it first first game that style I
had that crazy 3d you're like flying
down the thing it looks amazing I feel
64 takes those lessons doesn't better
gives you more variety you've got more
branching paths different planets all
that good stuff so I really like the
variety and how well everything but is
executing 64 which I don't feel is then
as well executed and hand on the BS cuz
it they had a bunch of weird just a lot
of weird stuff so rare is your is like
your favorite developer they were my
favorite developer for you not anymore
not or not you're not pouting kinect
sports rivals or anything definitely but
but at this to it so how is it for this
game slip through your cracks how did
you never play this game before uh it
came out in two thousand and in you may
remember yeah in September of 99 aha Jim
Jessica okay and that was kind of it for
me yeah like I probably played a couple
other than 64 games but it's yes I mean
there's the same thing with donkey kong
country sits or games don't go just
ignore right this is you know once you
play the dreamcast you don't want to go
this game looks surprisingly bad by the
way well it looks you know what it looks
some it it looks just like fuzzy it
looks like the art would be really good
if you could just peel back this like
layer of fuzziness to simply covering
everything like the colors are really
kind of vibrant and beautiful and have
this kind of like watercolor thing going
on I think it's I think the color is
very nice i just think they it's it last
definition be nice had a small team and
they kind of crap this out I don't know
wonder if this is a passion project for
them or I got to get paid projects those
are the best projects better way gotta
get big a different project yeah and
when i'm done with this stream i'm
probably gonna go and read the gamespot
review and see what yeah jeff gerstmann
or whoever whoever do a short straw we
have freelance this one yeah my not have
been Junkers yeah I don't know what
maybe it was making all the swing by his
desk and talk about this while he tries
to get rid of me one of your favorite
things to do yeah hey Jeff what's going
on oh hi Tom huh it's funny that's not
true but it totally could be totally
could be sure you could be like the
obnoxious like sitcom you know neighbor
the neighbor yeah I'll be like sitting
from from family time well you knew
exactly what i remember Skippy this is
this is this game actually like maybe I
should do a close critical analysis in
this game huh i'm pretty sure it's
mocking America because my weapon is a
baseball right i had the baseball or
yeah yeah has nothing to do with this
mean nothing to do with any of these
characters but it's an America I should
be base but there should also be like
slices of apple pie yeah Mike throw at
your opponent do you think rarest is
mopping America tell relay this is like
whoa I love old rare I don't know if
I've mentioned this before even this
game is making me love them this is not
a great now it's fine it's fine it's
toll invited I rented this from
blockbuster I probably would have
thought it was good for you know a
little bit of fun